so long america first joe biden already
well on his way toward undoing four
years of president trump's
accomplishments
biden's transition team is partying like
his 2008.
he's stocking his cabinet with obama-era
relics like career bureaucrat tony
blinken who will be biden's secretary of
state
oh and that's not all john kerry he's
back
he's going to be the administration's
new climate czar
greg i am excited to see uh what john
kerry what work he's had done to his
face but other than that
i mean he could destroy i don't know our
standing in the world in terms of energy
dominance
well uh yellen is 74. carrie
is a spry i like it when they say spry
because that means you're old
he's a spry 76 so i'm just curious what
biden has against people who were born
in the 1950s or up
because apparently he's just stuck in
the 40s and it's like
it here's the problem and i think people
are going to figure this out especially
the media what
what does it mean trump has spoiled it
for everybody
because you just they're going right
back to the trough
the drop of all the same names the same
insiders
the same squalid bureaucrats
that don't do squat and they're back
there and they just have to wait around
they're just waiting around for four
years they wait around they write a few
books they do some
consulting and then when a democrat
comes in or let's say a republican they
just come back and they get another job
they hang out they get to
see their friends and eat at the fine
restaurants at dc trump
exposed all this trump hired outsiders
right
he when he hired insiders he got screwed
so he taught everybody everybody's eyes
are open right now
we see what's going on we can't take
this seriously
right and what is cnn going to do right
you know what cnn is like
if trump leaves we don't know that yet
but if he leaves
what is cnn like cnn is like a house
that's put up for sale
that a murder took place in it's like
how
no one's gonna it's like it's like oh
that's cnn that's a trump that's a trump
place
what happened there this is really bad
there's a trump place
yeah yeah who's that bald guy over there
oh that's uh that's that fact we're
gonna have to raise it
we're gonna have to make it but it's
that's what it is it's like a house
where a murder took place and there and
that's why they're selling it and you
could probably
trump could buy cnn for a steal right
now
richard don't do that richard listen
when president-elect biden ran he said
he would make sure that his cabinet
looked like america
and from these announcements that's
exactly what he plans to do for the
first time a latino man will head up the
department of homeland security and
after he's good
he's more than qualified uh an
african-american woman over 35 years of
experience
in foreign and foreign relations will
head up the united nations post here
in new york 35 years of experience
in kenya we can go on and on right but
once again what joe biden is giving you
here is people who understand how to run
government
the number one problem that donald trump
had in the first year of his
administration
was a whole bunch of folks who had no
idea how to run the government that's
why we loved it
but that's why the government didn't
work effectively no way it was the best
government we've seen in years
and for the record and to be fair all of
those individuals who work for him they
all have left and said he's horrible
including rex tillerson
tell me about that we could go down the
list of those votes
for that you're a liberal richard got
off to a rough start because there was a
coup
remember the witch hunt that was the
rough start so that was what mad dog
mattis does
i like the difference between how the
media characterizes these picks with
trump
if trump appoints somebody that he knows
really well
the media calls them a trump loyalist
very pejoratively
but if biden appoints someone he knows
really well oh it's a long time advisor
it's a very close confident
and and and the same thing the way they
characterize the guy's resume tony
blinken this is what the washington post
called them
they said lincoln is a centrist with
deep respect for institutions
he's there to rebuild our global world
order
and has a reputation as a
non-ideological
consensus builder this is a hard news
article that's not an opinion article
so how easy it is to be a democrat when
you have the media
writing press releases for you like that
i looked at blink and myself
and the guys for every single
intervention in the middle east
he's soft on china and he wants more and
more refugees to come to america now
that's not necessarily where the rest of
the country is so i wouldn't call that
centrist
there could is a consensus that he has a
great head of hair
and i will give him that and that's a
good jumping off point for me
personally right now it looks like greg
is right as usual mr gutfeld
if this is a return to normalcy to
boring people to people that have done
this for years
career diplomats people in the obama and
the clinton administration
these aren't revolutionary ideas they're
not even bright ideas that these people
have
they're there not to rock the boat and
then people else can get rich
while everybody else isn't looking we do
know what john kerry is capable of
paris climate accord in the iran nuclear
deal which basically
hands money and power to nations that
hate us it's like here
take some of our our money and then use
it to try and wipe us off the map
i think that they're not going to be
able or even i don't even think they're
going to change things as much because
let me just tell you i think that for
example nato is now paying more
than they were four years ago do you
think that biden is going to say
actually no we don't need that money no
i don't think that's going to change
i think that a lot of people on the left
uh including bernie sanders liked the
new approach on china
and i think that joe biden's eyes have
been opened on that and i
i don't think that's going to change i
think the iran deal how
if there are going to go back into that
that's going to take some really good
communications to try to explain to the
american people why that makes sense
when we've seen
how they've been stymied and there was
something new so i actually don't think
that foreign policy turns quickly like
that i think that a lot more domestic
policy could change
and i would say that biden is content to
be the antidote to trump right he said
he's going to campaign as like return to
normal guy
everybody that he's announced is
somebody that has been already confirmed
by the united states senate there's a
strategy there to be like i don't want
to get hung up in maybe a mitch
mcconnell senate
i want to be able to say look you
already approved these guys four years
ago what's the problem
try to check them off